[Musique]
un bon soir lundi 26 avril bienvenue
dans cette édition spéciale préparé par
la rédaction de tv 60,18 voici les
titres les yvelines de nouveau touchée
par le terrorisme stéphanie n
fonctionnaires de police de 49 ans a été
tué lors d'une attaque au couteau
vendredi au commissariat de rambouillet
trois jours après l'attentât un
rassemblement était organisé ce lundi
soir sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
ce week-end déjà des yvelinois sont
venus rendre hommage à la victime sur le
lieu des faits l assaillant a été abattu
lors de l'attaqué qu'il s'agit d'un
tunisien de 36 ans qui n'était pas connu
des services de renseignement le parquet
national anti terroriste s'est saisi de
l'enquêté cinq personnes ont été placées
en garde à vue dans le week end
le rappel des faits les derniers
éléments de l'enquète à suivre et puis
c'est un assassinat qui intervient
quelques jours après cette annonce du
ministère de l'intérieur un renfort de
128 policier sera effective dans les
yvelines et du saupoudrage selon
certains syndicats invités tout au long
de cette édition julien le cam du
syndicat alliance police nationale 78
cette image pour débuter comme ici à
maurepas plusieurs mairies yvelinoise
ont mis leur drapeau en berne
c'est le cas également à villepreux ou
encore aux clayes-sous-bois l'hommage de
ses communes à stéphanie m vendredi
dernier cette agente administrative du
commissariat de rambouillet a été tué à
l'armé blanche
le drame est survenu peu avant 14h30 au
niveau du sas du bâtiment retour sur les
faits et sur les derniers éléments de
l'enquète avec justin brasier le
département des yvelines à nouveau
touché par une attaque terroriste
après l'assassinât de samuel pâtit le 16
octobre dernier le commissariat de
rambouillet a été visé par une attaque
vendredi 23 avril
la victime stéphanie mère de famille de
49 ans est adjointe administrative au
commissariat a reçu deux coups de
couteau mortel de son assaillant le
premier ministre jean castex s'est rendu
sur place accompagné du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin
il a exprimé son soutien à la famille
aux policiers et aux fonctionnaires du
commissariat de rambouillet je voudrais
dire à l'ensemble des françaises et des
français
combien notre détermination à lutter
contre le terrorisme sous toutes ses
formes
est plus que jamais intact l'auteur des
faits de nationalité tunisienne serait
inconnu des services de renseignement
neutralisé par des fonctionnaires de
police il est décédé sur place
le parquet national anti terroriste
s'est saisi de l'enquêté
pour l'heure les investigations se
poursuivent cinq personnes ont été
placées en garde à vue
de nouvelles précisions sur l'attaqué
ont été donné ce dimanche à 14h25
la victime faisait retour vers le
commissariat puis actionnait la sonnerie
afin de permettre l'ouverture de la
première porte du sas et pénétrait dans
ce nid si dans le même temps jamais le g
après avoir récupéré son sac posé au sol
courait en direction de la victime
l'auteur des faits s'était rapidement
engouffré derrière la victime lorsque
celle ci avait pu franchir la première
porte du sas suite au drame plusieurs
élus locaux ont souhaité s'exprimer on a
voulu frapper là encore un symbole de la
france parce que nos policiers sont la
france ils sont le visage de la france
et on a cherché aussi à déstabiliser le
pays en venant ici
s'attaquer aux forces de police dans
cette ville si tranquille du sud rural
de l'île de france et un quartier
tranquille c'est une ville tranquille
ce sont des fonctionnaires de police qui
font leur métier de manière absolument
exemplaire au quotidien ils savent que
chaque jour potentiellement ils peuvent
mettre leur vie en jeu mais là rien rien
évidemment ne laissait présager un tel
drame pour une fonctionnaire à une
initiative l'infamie terroriste
s'attaque de nouveau à notre communauté
nationale
lâchement en choisissant une symbolique
puissante une femme policière dans un
commissariat
c'est une nouvelle épreuve pour la
france et pour les français j'apprends
avec effroi l'assassinât d'une
fonctionnaire de police du commissariat
de rambouillet cette ville qui m'est si
chère une victime de plus du terrorisme
islamiste
je veux exprimer tout mon soutient la
famille de la victime ainsi qu'à ses
collègues policiers
encore une fois durement touchés plus
que jamais nous devons être à leurs
côtés
suite à ce drame la sécurité devant les
commissariats de police et les brigades
de gendarmerie va être renforcée et
trois jours après la
taquin rassemblement était organisé ce
lundi soir sur le parvis de la mairie de
rambouillet on retrouve d'ailleurs sur
place
célia gars de son beau bonsoir bonsoir
et l'hommage s'est terminée il ya
quelques minutes c'est bien oui il vient
tout juste de finir là où je me trouve
sur le parvis de la mairie de
rambouillet des centaines de personnes
étaient présentes pour rendre hommage à
stéphanie cette policière tuée vendredi
alors véronique matillon à la maire de
rambouillet a fait un discours sobre
mais à peine cinq minutes
s'en est suivie la marseillaise et puis
une minute de silence
de nombreuses personnalités étaient
présentes 1 il y avait eu gérard larcher
sénateur des yvelines mais aussi valérie
pécresse la présidente d'île de france
aurore bergé beaucoup beaucoup de deux
personnalités et des élus locaux aussi
et puis parmi les présents noël y avait
des habitants comme hostile diane
bonjour s'ils viennent
bonjour ça nous tenait à coeur d'être
présente aujourd'hui tout à fait je
tenais absolument à rendre hommage à
stéphanie son époux ses enfants toute sa
famille et surtout soutenir les forces
de l'ordre il est urgent que ces
violences cessent c'est urgent voilà ce
qu'on pouvait dire en tout cas ici donc
à la mairie de rambouillet merci célia
400 go pour ces précisions et merci à
justine brasier pour les moyens
techniques et non viendront bien sûr sur
ce rassemblement dans notre édition de
demain mardi sur tv 78 ce week end déjà
des habitants de rambouillet était venu
rendre hommage à la fonctionnaire de
police devant le commissariat de la
ville là où s'est déroulée la tacc entre
choc et incompréhension michael et demi
d'euros et célia gars tsongo ont pu
recueillir quelques réactions
vous voyez j'ai pas pleurer comme ça
depuis la mort de mon mari c'est le choc
pour les rambolitains après le meurtre
de la fonctionnaire de police stéphanie
qui a été tué vendredi 23 avril à
l'entrée du commissariat de rambouillet
où elle travaillait de nombreux
habitants sont venus lui rendre hommage
en déposant des fleurs devant l'hôtel de
police
touchés ils soutiennent cette famille
endeuillée pourquoi on méritait pas cela
personne ne mérite ça moi j'ai deux
chiens aussi mon ami aussi faim deux
orphelins c'est assez terrible terrible
elle faisait que son boulot je veux
donner mon soutien aux policiers je
trouve qu'ils sont bien mal traités
c'est horrible mais ça va changer parce
que cette femme encore une fois n'était
pas n'importe qui on est tous touchés
c'est atterrante de penser à cette mère
de famille qui est parti vendredi matin
qui a quitté son domicile qui a dû
embrasser ses filles et qu'il reviendra
pas stéphanie avait 49 ans et vivait
avec son mari et ses deux filles dans le
village de saint léger en yvelines
à quelques kilomètres de rambouillet une
ville paisible selon ses habitants c'est
vachement call c'est pas du tout s
compenser mon papa arriver n'importe où
mais bon c'est quand même assez touchant
bas ici rambouillet oui c'est arrivé
c'est la première fois un loup dit les
gens qui prennent pas gérant bolton le
compagnie pour les yvelines et plus
particulièrement la police sont une
nouvelle fois endeuillée après le couple
de policiers assassinés à magnanville en
2016 mais je vous propose à présent
d'écouter cette réaction celle de
véronique matillon élu en juin dernier
maire de rambouillet après le choc les
dix l'appellent ses habitants à garder
espoir et à rester unis
elle était l'invité ce matin de patrice
carmouze dans l'émission paf sur tv 78
les rambolitains sont encore sous le
choc et ont du mal à réaliser mais d'un
autre côté
aussi mon rôle est aussi de leur dire
combien nous devons continuer à croire à
l'attractivité de notre ville parce que
nous avons été frappés par ce cet
attentat n'est que ça aurait pu arriver
n'importe où garder l'espoir restait
unie parce que c'est en étant unie que
nous sommes forts et nous allons
continuer à faire famille
si je puis dire pour affronter ce qui
vient nous arrivait nous en relever
parce que c'est aussi rendre hommage à
la fois stéphanie à la fois sa famille
est à la fois ses collègues de les
souvenirs d'être fort de notre côté pour
pouvoir les soutenir des missions
complètes à retrouver en replay sur
notre site internet tv 78 points comme
nous également sur notre application
mobile tv 78
ce nouvel acte terroriste ne peut que
rappeler l'actualité récente dans le
département des yvelines bonsoir
eléonore sinoquet lombez de la rédaction
de tv 60,18 les yvelines ont déjà été
touché à deux reprises par la barbarie
en effet troisième acte un troisième
attentat pardon en près de cinq années
grégory ce nouvel acte terroriste ne
peut évidemment que rappeler le crime
odieux le 13 juin 2016 à magnanville où
deux policiers déjà se sont fait
assassiner génica jessica sneider agente
administrative au commissariat de mantes
la jolie et son compagnon jean baptise
salvin commissaire adjoint aux mureaux
ils avaient été attaqués à l'armé
blanche à leur domicile un pavillon d'un
quartier tranquille de magnanville sous
les yeux de leurs enfants
le terroriste se réclamant de l'état
islamique avait été abattu par le raid
autre attentat et a endeuillé les
yvelines le 2ème plus récemment le 16
octobre 2020 samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire géographie au collège le bois
donne de conflans sainte honorine
avaient été décapités à la sortie de son
établissement une attaque faisant suite
à une campagne de calomnie contre
l'enseignant suit un cours sur la
liberté d'expression qui le professeur
avait donné à ces élèves où il avait
montré des caricatures pardon de mahomet
l'une des élèves avaient avoué ensuite
avoir menti
on perd racontant avoir été victime de
discrimination
le parent avait alors posté une vidéo
sur internet des images qui ont conduit
le terroriste a visé samuel pâtit
l'assaillant avait alors été abattus
dans un face à face avec la police
merci à l'honneur pour ces précisions
j'accueille à présent julien lucarne
d'enfance bonsoir vous êtes le
secrétaire régional du syndicat alliance
police nationale dans les yvelines et
stéphanie m 49 ans travaillait comme
fonctionnaires administratifs depuis 28
ans au commissariat de rambouillet
comment avez-vous réagi suite à cette
attaque comment les policiers plus
généralement haute il réagit est ce que
vous avez peut-être pu échanger avec
quelques-uns de ses collègues
oui alors c'est un véritable choc
d'ailleurs je voulais commencer mon
intervention en rendant hommage à notre
collègue stéphanie à ses proches à ses
collègues et on peut parler oui d'un
véritable choc au commissariat de
rambouillet sur le département
est ce que vous avez pu échanger
justement avec des avec ses collègues
policiers
oui oui j'ai j'ai échangé avec eux avec
mes collègues qui ne comprennent pas
qu'ils qui sont vraiment trop forts
profondément touchés ils sont
complètement effondrés il faut savoir
que cette cette collègue travaillait là
depuis bientôt trente ans dans le
commissariat elle était très appréciée
et c'est un véritable choc mans d'autant
que cette circonscription de rambouillet
et à l'accoutumée une circonscription
plutôt calme oui c'est une
circonscription de police on va dire de
taille moyenne avec sa délinquance
quotidienne c'est voilà c'est quelques
événements c'est c'est un commissariat
oui une agglomération relativement calme
on va dire sur sur le départ sur le
département des yvelines
et c'est c'est un vrai aux tables
cataclysme qui s'est passé vendredi un
drame
comme malheureusement dans les yvelines
on est au troisième attentat terroriste
en moins de cinq ans magnanville
l'attentât de magnanville est encore
dans les esprits et vendredi en voilà on
est tous on est tous choqués par ce qui
s'est passé on en parlait il ya un
instant ce cette attente un réveil
forcément le souvenir douloureux de
magnanville l'assassinât des policiers
jessica schnyder et et jean baptiste
seulement c'était en 2007 vous le disais
c'est encore dans toutes les têtes
parmi les policiers des yvelines ah oui
malgré que ça date d'il ya cinq ans
savoir que beaucoup de collègues qui ont
côtoyé le couple savin travaille encore
sur le département c'est quelque chose
qui a profondément marqué les
fonctionnaires de ce département et ce
qui s'est passé vendredi
voilà où réouvert cette plaie et il faut
savoir que le département c'est tout le
monde se connaît tout le monde se côtoie
c'est un petit milieu c'est on pourrait
comparer ça voilà un petit village tout
le monde se connaît et tout le monde
c'est comme une famille est là toute la
famille est touchée
à travers ce drame ils se sentent visés
les policiers même 55 ans après après ce
drame mais il ya encore à un nouveau
drame qui s'est noué à rambouillet
vendredi il ya une inquiétude
particulière parmi les policiers
ouais mais c'est quelque chose qui
frappe comme ça qui ne prévient pas
c'est quelque chose de 10 père violent
d'hyper soudain vous avez notre collègue
qui a neutralisé le terroriste qui a
réagi très rapidement
c'est quelque chose qui ne se fait
évidemment qui ne se prévoit pas qu'ils
ne sentent ici pas et forcément cette
violence de l'attaqué c'est soudaineté
et je voulais souligner d'ailleurs le
sang froid de notre collègue qui a
neutralisé
malgré tout rapidement le terrorisme et
qui a évité un véritable carnage face à
un individu qui a été déterminé et
et qui a malheureusement à tuer stefani
quelques heures après la taille de
renvoyer le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin a demandé aux préfets de
renforcer la sécurité aux abords des
commissariats et des brigades de
gendarmerie ce que c'est une juste
réponse à apporter dans cette urgence
est ce que c'est déjà visible ce
renforcement de la sécurité dans les
airs et nous pas encore le renfort n'en
là on est plutôt dans une phase de
démantèlement de la sécurité dans les
yvelines depuis des années on supprime
des postes tous les ans on a supprimé
une centaine de postes en deux ans trois
cent dix ans l'équivalent de plusieurs
commissariats on peut pas parler de
renfort du tout bien au contraire il ya
un vrai un vrai recul en termes de
moyens humains et matériels en termes de
sécurité
ce qui est en totale contradiction avec
ces annonces
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler tout à
l'heure restez avec nous julien le câble
effectivement vous parlez d'une annonce
un celle du gouvernement d'un renfort de
128 policiers dans le département des
yvelines mais avant ça nous allons
écouter à présent une autre réaction
celle de françois bersani est d'un autre
syndicat de policiers le syndicat unité
sgp police 78 tout d'abord c'est un
sentiment de stupéfaction de
consternation de sidération pour d'abord
tous nos personnels de ce commissariat
de rambouillet pour nous mêmes les
représentants du personnel on était on
est tous les jours quasi monde dans ce
commissariat de rambouillet notre
collègue stéphanie était très apprécié
et très implantée depuis 28 ans c'était
un pilier de ce commissariat et
aujourd'hui il ya vraiment une peine
immense qui a envahi tous nos collègues
du commissaire aux gardiens de la paix
c'est un c'est un moment très difficile
à passer pour nos collègues nous en
parlions cette attaque intervient une
semaine après l annonce de renforts de
policiers dans les yvelines eléonore
sinoquet de la rédaction de tv 78
toujours avec moi que faut-il retenir de
ces annonces justement de renforts eh
bien d'abord ses 128 fonctionnaires de
police qui devrait arriver d'ici peu
dans plusieurs commissariats yvelinois
dans le détail
onze policiers sont attendus à
versailles 18 à conflans sainte honorine
23 à elancourt 21 à mantes la jolie et
16 as à trouville enfin pour saint
germain en laye
elle sera dotée la commune de 39
personnel supplémentaire est-ce qu'il
faut préciser que ces excès ville
correspondent en fait à des
circonscriptions de sécurité publique
qui parfois regroupe plus de dix
communes exactement grégory celle de
saint germain l'a par exemple est la
plus grande avec quatorze communes à
couvrir ce renfort de 39 personnel est
donc une bonne chose pour la
municipalité
la première action c'est que c'est une
bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour la circonscription les alors les
treize ou quatorze communes c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour notre commune
nouvelle notre ville
et puis c'est aussi une très bonne
nouvelle pour les policiers c'est 39
policiers je pense que ça doit rattraper
une bonne partie des policiers qui qui
sont partis ou enfin en tout cas qu'ils
n'étaient plus là depuis quelques années
nuance est donc mais plutôt satisfaits
saint germain en laye en revanche ce
n'est pas le cas du tout de l'ensemble
du territoire y vinoy certaines
circonscriptions n'auront pas de renfort
à rambouillet ou encore aux mureaux mais
également à plaisir ou la première édile
joséphine comme mal ce verger a organisé
une conférence de presse ce lundi pour
exprimer son mécontentement
tout comme les cinq autres villes de la
circonscription les clayes-sous-bois
saint cyr l'école bois d'arcy villepreux
et fontenay le fleury devant le
commissariat de plaisir donc aujourd'hui
les élus par la voix de joséphine
coleman ce berger ont demandé à gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur de
revoir sa copie il était important de
faire cette conférence de presse pour
peut-être faire un appel un peu plus
ferme auprès du ministère de l'intérieur
et du ministre de l'intérieur lui-même
pour que ils viennent ici et qu'ils
constatent de visu les difficultés que
nous avons il nous faut des effectifs
c'est pas possible il doit revoir sa
copie
il y a dû y avoir un loupé alors on veut
bien comprendre que la nul n'est parfait
mais mais il faut la revoir
de leur côté les syndicats de police
aussi estiment que ces renforts sont
loin d'être suffisants aujourd'hui on
assiste en fait un saupoudrage en
matière d'effectifs en fonction de l'
influence de tel ou tel élu de tel ou
tel député ou de visites ministérielles
dans tel ou tel commissariat quand vous
n'avez pas d'élus de poids quand vous
n'avez pas de déplacement le ministre
est bien comme ici à plaisir comme
d'ailleurs rambouillet ou
murrow qui ne sont pas concernés par les
renforts eh bien vous avez la situation
qui continue à se dégrader selon
françois bersani que l'on vient
d'entendre 280 postes ont été supprimés
dans les yvelines depuis 2010 merci à
l'honneur pour ses nouvelles précisions
et julia le cas mais toujours avec nous
vous êtes le secrétaire régional du
syndicat alliance police nationale dans
les yvelines
on parlait tout à l'heure vous avez une
première réaction sur ces renforts qui
ont été annoncés il ya quelques jours
par emmanuel macron dix mille policiers
et gendarmes supplémentaires à l'échelle
de la france 128 postes qui concerne
elle les yvelines n'est pas d'ailleurs à
la circonscription de rambouillet qui a
été endeuillé par la taille de vendredi
est ce que ces renforts sont bienvenues
alors tout à l'heure vous aviez une
première réaction ou est ce plutôt du
saupoudrage comme le dénoncent certains
syndicats de policiers alors il faut
voir l'effet de communication qui est
fait derrière cette annonce nous il faut
voir si ces 128 policiers vont venir
s'ajouter aux effectifs actuels où ils
vont tout simplement venir remplacer les
futurs départs j'ai regardé le en
détaillant les chiffres annoncés on
parle de onze renfort par exemple au
commissariat de versailles
sauf que dans le même temps ce
commissariat tous les ans perd une
vingtaine d'effectifs pour le palier des
mutations ou par le biais des départs en
retraite
donc pour nous on ne peut pas appeler ça
un véritable renfort on appellera ça un
renfort quand les départs seront
remplacés et qu'on viendra ajouter ses
128 des effectifs qui sont annoncées sur
le département qui sont malgré tout
insuffisant puisque je vous l'annoncé on
a perdu l'équivalent de 300
fonctionnaires en dix ans et il faut
voir ces 128 fonctionnaires s'ils
viendront bien renforcée et non pas tout
simplement remplacer les départs mais
vous êtes en attente de plus
d'informations ça veut dire que ça ne
compense pas du tout aller vous parliez
300 et à le chiffre de 280 aussi j'ai vu
qu'ils circulaient ça ne compense pas du
tout ces départ depuis ses essais non
remplacement depuis ces dernières années
non du tout qui voyez par exemple sur
l'agglomération d'elancourt on annonce
une vingtaine de renforts c'est ce que
va perdre l'agglomération par le biais
des mutations puisque la province va
également énormément recruté
g ces renforts vont venir
essentiellement d'ile-de-france de
policiers aux franciliens qui comme tout
le monde par le biais de mutation et
leurs demandes vont être satisfait par
les mutations donc si on nous annonce 21
renfort à elancourt avec dedans même
temps on vous en perdez autant un biais
des mutations
il faut que ces 21 fonctionnaires
viennent en rajout de du remplacement
des futurs départs et on peut voir vu
les derniers événements au très violent
que que villes de l'agglomération
d'elancourt que c'est complètement
insuffisant pourquoi justement ces
renforts sont primordiaux on parle
souvent dans ses éditions du manque
d'effectifs de policiers dans les
yvelines
que pourrait-il vous permet de réaliser
au quotidien prenons un exemple de
rambouillet rambouillet qui s'occupe de
l'agglomération gerbe un peu plus un
bassin d'habitants depuis trente cinq
mille trente cinq mille habitants
et c'est une circonscription assez vaste
d'avoir des renforts à rambouillet
permettrait par exemple de rajouter une
patrouille supplémentaires actuellement
vous avez de manière globale une
patrouille sur l'agglomération de
rambouillet ce qui est complètement
insuffisant puisque malheureusement
souvent la deuxième patrouille est pris
sur ce qu'on appelle des tâches indues
ou des missions de gardes statiques
donc vous avez déjà beaucoup de
fonctionnaires qui sont utilisés hors
voie publique bon ça permettrait
forcément de d'accroître la présence sur
la voie publique est forcément de rendre
plus efficaces les interventions de
police qu'est ce que vous demandez
aujourd'hui peut-être davantage de
précisions vous le disiez ou manque de
clarté encore autour de ces annonces oui
évidemment et puis d'abord il ya aussi
les effets de com on voit monsieur
darmanin qui passent sur l'agglomération
de sartrouville et qui nous annonce
d'un coût 16 fonctionnaires
supplémentaires sachant que
l'agglomération on manque déjà d'une
cinquantaine de policiers
donc on peut se rendre compte que ils se
servent de ces enfants aussi comme
effets de com sachant que pendant des
années nous avons pas eu de renforts il
ya en deux ans en quatre policiers de
postes de policiers qui ont été
supprimés donc on part de très loin et
le contexte est tendu depuis plusieurs
jours la ville de trappes fait face à
des violences urbaines dans la nuit de
jeudi 22 au vendredi 23 avril lors d'une
patrouille une quarantaine de jeunes ont
pris pour cible la police au square léo
lagrange s'est ensuite le commissariat
de trappes qui a été visée par des tirs
de mortiers d'artifice les forces de
l'ordre ont riposté avec des tirs de l
bd des grenades lacrymogènes et des
faits similaires se sont produits
également dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche
écoutez à ce propos la réaction du maire
de trappes ali rabais collectées par
célia gars de 100 go
comme tous les trappistes et au delà
tous les yvelinois qui sont confrontés à
ces phénomènes depuis quelques jours le
maire de trappes est exaspéré évidemment
on est réveillé en pleine nuit par des
feux d'artifice par des affrontements
entre policiers et bandes de jeunes moi
j'ai dû trois nuits d'affilée aller sur
le terrain pour faire intervenir les
services techniques pour ramasser les
poubelles brûlées et ces phénomènes on
les vit à travers le département des
yvelines à sartrouville a plaisir à peu
près de chez nous à montigny à elancourt
et ça aboutit parfois des drames donc
j'appelle chacun à la responsabilité
j'appelle notamment les parents à
veiller à ce que leurs enfants soient
chez eux au moment du couvre-feu et
n'ont rien à faire dans les rues à
minuit à 1h du matin et j'appelle
également la population à se mobiliser
autour des élus autour du maire autour
des services municipaux parce qu'il faut
aller au contact
il ne faut pas uniquement laisser la
confrontation sera organisé entre
policiers et bandes de jeunes
mais nous irons contactez nous avons
fait ce week end julien le cas de la
situation devient de plus en plus tendue
en certains endroits dans les yvelines
oui alors il ya quelques années encore
les effets de violences urbaines
concerné on va dire quatre cinq communes
il faut savoir que ces pratiques se sont
quasiment généralisé sur toutes les
grandes communes du département
il ya quelques jours à sartrouville un
bus était incendiée par plusieurs
individus à plaisir des individus s'en
sont pris violemment à mes collègues est
on comment tirer et dégradé les caméras
de vidéosurveillance il faut savoir que
maintenant ça c'est quasiment généralisé
il ya une véritable montée en puissance
de ces violences urbaines et en
parallèle vous donner de moins en moins
de moyens
les instructions ne sont pas claires
pareil pour mes collègues à qui on
demande d'éviter certains secteurs pour
justement en éviter ces potentiels
tension et on demande donc à mes
collègues d'éviter certains quartiers
ouais merci julien le câble d'avoir été
avec nous tout au long de cette édition
spéciale
merci à vous et je rappelle que vous
êtes le secrétaire régional du syndicat
alliance police nationale 78
voilà ce que l'on pouvait vous dire
trois jours après la mort de stéphanie
aime cette fonctionnaire de police de 49
ans tué lors d'une attaque au couteau à
rambouillet elle nous vous tiendrons
bien sûr informés des prochaines
avancées de l'enquète cette édition
spéciale touche à sa fin merci de votre
fidélité très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]